I think there has to be some evolution
to the curriculum but I'm fairly old
fashioned and and I you know I like to
teach basic math skills and I feel that
in order to really master skills you
have to practice them so I may not be
the most innovative teacher in America
but I think you know I keep coming back
to the standards that we have every
teacher has his or her own skills and
preferences in terms of how to teach but
I think you know we have to make sure
that we learn the basics and you know I
one of the things I believe that happens
in education is that we we tend to latch
on to the latest reform idea I would
call it the reform du jour and i would
suggest most of these reform movements
that we have we tried before they're
recycled with a new name slapped on them
so i'm not a big fan of new reform ideas
and thinking that those reform efforts
are silver bullets I just don't think
this happens instead I believe that it's
the teacher who makes the difference so
if it's a question of a program versus a
person
it's the person that is far more
important than the program